und wir schauen jetzt direkt nach
afghanistan nach kabul zu paul
ronzheimer denn dort paul feiert man den
sogenannten independence day was spielt
sich da hinter dir gerade in kabul ab
patricia sind unfassbare bilder wir sind
etwas außerhalb und kabul in ladakh
ungefähr eine stunde autofahrt entfernt
und ihr hinter mir siehst du die massen
tausende taliban viele kinder
mitgebracht sie feiern den sieg über die
internationalen truppen sie haben die
klagen des emirats dabei sie jubeln sie
sagen wir sind glücklich darüber dass
sie abgezogen sind dass die usa mit
ihrem letzten soldaten wechseln und ich
zeig dir einmal hier ja was kann man
einmal mit wie es hier aussieht gehen ja
einmal durch ist hier ganz viele kinder
auf dieser seite wir sehen hier ganz
viele menschen die sozusagen den sieg
über die internationalen truppen feiern
und du siehst das denn tausende menschen
darunter darunter auch darunter auch
viele viele viele viele viele viele
anführer gibt möglicherweise bald hier
im parlament sieht
fall wie wird das dort gefeiert wir
sehen die menschen in bagdad haben sich
versammelt kinder werden im mitgebracht
wir sehen auch viele die neugierig bei
dir in die kamera schauen beschreibt uns
einmal die stimmung ist wird als feier
bezeichnet dennoch sehen wir dich man
kann es nicht anders sagen umzingelt von
terroristen jetzt sollte in afghanistan
an der macht sind
das ist ja das ist eine situation die
ich mir
passieren würde dass in afghanistan die
taliban diese macht haben
wir müssen ein bisschen aufpassen denn
wir sind natürlich auch hochrangige
militärs hier sind die anführer der
taliban möglicherweise auch derjenige
der am ende verdammt der am ende
sozusagen hier derjenige sein wird der
die macht in afghanistan übernimmt ich
gehe noch einmal mit euch in diese
richtung
und ich vielleicht einmal mitnehmen hier
an dieser stelle salam und du siehst
hier diese bilder das sind kinder die
hier mitgebracht wurden natürlich die
wollen zeigen dass ist der sieg jetzt
ihm gehört afghanistan die taliban haben
uns besiegt haben die amerikaner besiegt
haben alle besiegt muss man sagen und
auch alle überrascht und vorher in den
straßen haben wir militärfahrzeuge wir
sehen wir haben die sozusagen fahrzeuge
gesehen die von den amerikanern erobert
wurden ich will noch einmal wir umgehend
und dass sie vielleicht noch mal ein
bild bekommt hier seht ihr die kinder
alle mit ihren flaggen dabei ja was
zeigt bitte noch einmal hier auf das
große feld damit wir so hoch seien hier
könnt ihr die dimension sehen derjenigen
wie viele menschen hier sind das ist der
absolute wahnsinn muss ich sagen und wir
haben wohin auch schon jubelschreie
gehört wir haben gesehen wie die
menschen das feiern wir sehen hier
werden auch gebetsteppiche ausgelegt in
diesem moment schließen immer wieder
natürlich bewacht hier konnten in tampa
paul das sind bilder bei denen wir hier
wie bisschen ratlos im studio stehen und
eigentlich nur kopfschütteln können
angesichts dieser szene mich würde
interessieren wie das im restlichen land
aufgenommen wird also wie muss ich das
jetzt mir vorstellen ist dass der
taliban mob sozusagen der da unter sich
ist und feiert und in weiten teilen des
landes guckt man da auch mit befremdung
irgendwie drauf oder ist das im grunde
heute was die nennen das
unabhängigkeitstag was ja groß teile
afghanistans heute erfasst wo die leute
mit feiern im land
bei also als wir aus kabul losgefahren
sind haben wir jetzt keine menschen auf
der straße gesehen die das gefeiert
haben das ist natürlich die
organisierten taliban allerdings wenn
man durch die straßen geht auch das ist
wichtig zu sagen wir bekommen als
reporter keine ehrliche antwort mehr von
den menschen darauf auf die frage wie
sie sich fühlen natürlich haben alle
angst davor vor repressalien davor wie
ist am ende mit ihnen weitergeht
deswegen ist es ganz schwer ein
stimmungsbild zu bekommen ein gefühl war
auch in den vergangenen wochen als ich
hier war dass sie mehr unterstützung
haben als wir uns das im besten
vielleicht wünscht das liegt natürlich
auch daran dass die afghanische
regierung der massen korrupt war das ist
da so große probleme gehabt die armut
und so weiter ich mag da keine
prozentzahl zu nennen aber es ist nicht
so dass die taliban keine unterstützung
ganz im gegenteil du siehst die bilder
hier wird es noch einmal ihr dort bist
du die vielen vielen menschen die
schlagen dort überall und es strömen
immer weitere hier herscheid wir gehen
vielleicht noch einmal hier runter
einfach um euch ein bild zu zeigen davon
wie das hier aussieht die menschen
schauen uns natürlich etwas neugierig an
ich bin glaube ich der einzige
westliche aussehende menschen der von
ihr berichtet zumindest habe ich niemand
anderen bislang gesehen und hier siehst
du die ganze dimension dessen das sind
diejenigen hier sind sehen wir die
kinder aber dahinter sei das sind
diejenigen die gegen die internationalen
druck gekämpft haben über 20 jahre das
waren unsere feinde einst und jetzt
feiern sie hier jetzt feiern sie den
sieg über uns das sind diejenigen die am
ende auch anschlägen gegen
bundeswehrsoldaten
geplant haben und jetzt sagen sie wenn
ich interviews mit ihrem schüler wir
wollen wir wollen gute beziehungen zum
besten wir wollen gute diplomatische
beziehung auch wenn es so aussieht paul
das musst mich nochmal eine ordnung
vertreter als wer paul da der
geisterfahrer der einzige mit der aus
dem westen kommt also das mag sich
vielleicht für dich so anfühlen habe die
geisterfahrer sind eindeutig die anbauer
gut ich kann ja nur beschreiben was ich
in dem moment aber es ist natürlich so
dass die situation hier immer ein
bisschen brenzlig ist ganz viele
bewaffnete truppen wir müssen mal wieder
erklären würde ich auch was wir machen
das geht nur dadurch dass wir gute
afghanische kontakte haben wir haben
gesehen wie hier da ließ man mit ihren
motorrädern rhein sind mit ihren
militärfahrzeugen also das ist hier eine
machtdemonstration und der sieg über die
internationalen druck
wir sehen die kinder die da angeordnet
sitzen müssen so zumindest scheint es
für mich das nicht den eindruck dass
hier sehe ich jetzt in voller spannung
alle freiwillig eingesetzt haben ich
sehe aber keine einzige frau
ja ich habe auch noch keine gesehen und
das sind ja vor allem hier sozusagen die
kämpfer die sich versammelt haben dann
mit ihren söhnen um mir zu feiern aber
nein bauen sind hier nicht zu sehen
das ist sicherlich auch ein zeichen und
ein symbol was hier auf dieses land
kommt und wenn ich mich umschaue dann
schauen uns natürlich viele viele an und
sagen sich was wir eigentlich tun es
sind immer wieder sie sind blicke jetzt
während er mit uns spricht die männer
gehen an dir vorbei schauen dich von
oben bis unten an jesus gefühle wie
wirst du da derzeit als einziger
journalist der von dort berichtet
überhaupt aufgenommen du hast uns mal
berichtet manchmal fühlen sie sich sogar
richtig stolz sehr stolz auf ihren sieg
stolz dass dieser sieg gezeigt wird
jetzt aber sieht man in den augen auch
durchaus skepsis wie fühlt sich das auch
für dich an
vertriebs ja das ist unser job hier zu
berichten und ich denke dann nicht zu
viel darüber nach was wäre
wahrscheinlich auch nicht gut ich plane
aller dinge gut ich habe viele kontakte
hier und natürlich diese menschen das
darf man ja nicht vergessen die haben 20
jahre vor allem in den hügeln gelebt in
den bergen wir haben keine westlich aus
den menschen die mich gesehen die bahn
das erste mal vielleicht den haben in
ihrem leben nachdem die taliban
übernommen haben und das ist für sie
einfach ein ganz neues bild das gibt es
nicht deswegen ist das einfach aus
neugier sicherlich und man muss sagen
natürlich ist es eine situation die für
für mich etwas ungewöhnliche ja für uns
alle das sind wirklich unglaubliche
bilder paul auch wie neugierig du immer
an geblickt wirst und wir schauen ja
ganz genauso neugierig zurück und auf
diese bilder und es ist für uns
mindestens genau so befremdlich was wir
sehen wie sich offenbar diese männer
fühlen wenn sie dich gerade anschauen
paul sind beschreibt sein ganz kurz du
sprichst immer von fire also besonders
ausgelassen sieht das ja nicht aus es
gibt nichts zu essen es gibt lediglich
viele waffen und eben ausschließlich
männer also woraus besteht jetzt ganz
genau eine feier bei den taliban
also es besteht daraus dass hier
sicherlich leicht noch einzelne anführer
sprechen werden wir haben gerade schon
sprechchöre gehören wir haben sätze
gehört gegen den besten sozusagen der
sieg der hier zelebriert wurde es wurden
wurde gerufen sieg über den westen hier
und die über die internationalen truppen
von den anführern
und das wird jetzt jedoch stundenlang so
weitergehen ich glaube dass noch nicht
alle bislang hier sind obwohl ich erst
wenn wir da sozusagen hier sehen wie
viele menschen ist denn dann kann man
sich vorstellen was hier los ist das
sind
[Musik]